ahead of chief executive Carrie lambs
policy address security was increased
around the government complex
anticipating protesters a wall was
extended and more police were added but
they did not plan for disruption to come
from inside the Legislative Council
twice Lam tried to deliver her address
twice she was drowned out by members of
the opposition pen democracy coalition
chanting and holding up signs at one
point they projected the protest
movements 5 demands on the wall behind
her soon after the session was called
off because of the disruption
pro-democracy members held a news
conference with a clear message our five
demands are very clear not one less and
I really urge her if she can't govern
Hong Kong and she has no determination
to govern Hong Kong and she has no
ability and even incapable in
administrating Hong Kong please step
down
Carrie Lam was forced to put a plan B
into action having no success delivering
her address here in the Legislative
Council Chambers she had to do it
through a video feed my Daisy poet
carried live on Hong Kong TV it was the
first time a chief executive delivered a
policy address on video in it she
touched on some of the big issues the
people of Hong Kong have been calling
for improved livelihoods and more
affordable housing
she also addressed the deep divide in
Hong Kong society saying that an
independent committee will be set up to
look into those divisions later at a
news conference Lam said she'd tried to
listen to all views something she's
promised before well young white legal
in the past few months this very serious
social unrest has challenged our views
facing the incidents of recent months I
realized that being a politician I need
to be always aware and understand the
feelings of our people and while I also
understand that the intentions are good
we also need to be very tolerant and
open-minded
flam said that the theme of her policy
address this year was treasurer Hong
Kong our home but it's clear that
there's a lot more work to be done
before Hong Kong is a harmonious
household Scot Heidler al-jazeera Hong
Kong